und ich begrüße sehr herzlich henriette
rieker parteilose oberbürgermeisterin
der stadt köln afrika in köln gibt es
stadtteile in denen die sieben tage
incidents bei 5 bis 6 100 liegt also
weit über dem landesschnitt und ab heute
sollen mobile teams in insgesamt 15
sogenannten vulnerable ein sozialraum
gebieten impfen
sie würden gern 700 impfungen pro tag
verabreichen das land nrw will in der
ersten woche aber nur 1000 zusätzliche
impfdosen zur verfügung stellen das
heißt ihr vorhaben wird vom
nrw-gesundheitsminister laumann nicht in
vollem umfang unterstützt also ich finde
es wichtig dass wir jetzt beginnen dort
wo die menschen einen besonderen
infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt sind in
dieser dritten welle das ist mir ganz
wichtig das war nicht von beginn der
pandemie also da waren es andere
stadtteile zu impfen
und auch die möglichkeit zu haben sie in
der priorität priorisierung vorzuziehen
das land hat zunächst tatsächlich 1000
impfdosen angekündigt aber ich glaube
dass wenn wir wirklich angefangen haben
und wegen beginn ja heute erst dass wir
dann mehr brauchen und dass dem land
auch sehr deutlich machen können und
dann weiterhin unterstützt werden denn
im land ist ganz klar was das für die
stadt bedeutet das eben infektionsherde
in bestimmten stadtteilen sind die
sozial benachteiligt sind in diesen
sozial benachteiligten stadtteilen gibt
es ein hohes infektionsgeschehen das
haben sie gesagt dazu die gründe hierfür
sind teilweise sehr beengte
wohnverhältnisse aber auch eine
schlechte medizinische infrastruktur
es gibt aber auch bei einigen menschen
eine gewisse skepsis gegenüber impfungen
und dem virus allgemein was machen sie
denn wenn sich die menschen vor ort
überhaupt nicht impfen lassen wollen
also haben sie neben im personal auch
übersetzer sozialarbeiter vor ort die
erklären und vermitteln können
ja sie haben es schon richtig
eingestellt
natürlich ist es ganz wichtig die
menschen dort aufzuklären darüber dass
der impfstoff sicher ist wir werden auch
moderner und dann auch johnson johnson
verliefen um die größtmögliche
sicherheit schon vorab zu geben und
durch muttersprachliche unterstützung
und auch durch menschen die das
vertrauen genießen hoffen wir dass wir
da ein grosser einsichtsfähigkeit
erzeugen können wir werden sicherlich
die letzte und den letzten nicht davon
überzeugen können aber das ist nicht nur
in diesen stadtteilen der fall
sie wissen ja dass es auch immer noch
menschen gibt die gegen die impfung an
sich und ressentiments haben
johnson johnson als impfstoff weil hier
eben eine einmalige gabe eine einmalige
dosis zur immunisierung reicht und die
menschen nicht zweimal geimpft werden
müssen
oracle jetzt gibt es aber auch immer
noch besondere oder besonders
wohlhabende bevölkerungsgruppen die auch
noch auf ihre impfung warten außerhalb
dieser gebiete schaffen sie mit diesem
projekt der priorisierten impfung nicht
ein gerechtigkeitsproblem denn de facto
hebeln sie ja die im freien folge damit
aus nein wir hebeln die im freien folge
eben nicht aus es ist uns gelungen für
diese menschen in den stadt in den
sozialräumen eine priorisierung auf die
gruppe 3 vorzuziehen und die gruppe 3
ist jetzt dran und da haben wir mit
gesonderten impfstoff impfen entgeht
hier niemanden eine impfung die er sonst
bekommen hätte also es ist auch so dass
es eine maßnahme zur gefahrenabwehr ist
dh
wenn die menschen aus den stadtteilen
etwas wirklich infektiöser sind als
andere
geimpft werden dann nützt es uns alle
weil die können uns alle nicht mehr
anstecken
ja jetzt gibt es trotzdem kritische
stimmen zu dieser aktion die
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
gewerkschaft erziehung und wissenschaft
in nordrhein westfalen ein jahrzehnt zum
beispiel sagt wenn man jetzt menschen
aus sozial benachteiligten wohnvierteln
bevorzugt impft dann stigmatisiere man
diese zusätzlich das glaube ich nicht
weil wir ihnen ein zusätzliches angebot
machen und durch ein zusätzliches
angebot kann man niemanden
stigmatisieren
ich denke das wird diskutiert werden das
ist auch richtig
wie jede maßnahme diskutiert werden wird
wird sie befürworter und auch gegen frau
becker jetzt könnte es ja bald so sein
dass geimpfte und genesene von
einschränkenden maßnahmen ausgenommen
werden in ganz vielen bundesländern fast
allen ich glaube mit ausnahme hamburg
ist das ab heute auch schon so bevor es
eine bundeseinheitliche regelung gibt
könnte hier mit blick auf soziale
ungleichheit die situation entstehen
freiheit für besserverdiener und
ausgangssperren für die sozial schwachen
ja das ist ja eben gerade hier nicht der
fall weil hier werden ja die sozial
schwächeren geimpft aber ich glaube auch
diese diskussion wird sich verlaufen
dadurch dass mehr menschen in zukunft
geimpft sind und dass auch die geimpften
und die genesenen ja eine gewisse frist
haben dh sie werden ja nicht automatisch
sofort nach der ersten impfung können
sie sich frei bewegen
das ist ein grund rechtsproblem und
grundrechte hat man die bekommt man
nicht zurück sondern die kann man
einschränken und sobald die
einschränkungen nicht mehr
verfassungswidrig ist hat man das
grundrecht wieder das heißt man kann
sich wieder frei bewegen
allerdings gibt es kein grundrecht in
restaurant zu besuchen oder einen kaffee
oder ein konzert so weit geht es eben
nicht sondern es bezieht sich auf die
persönliche freiheit
jetzt waren es an diesem punkt
eigentlich wieder
die intensivmediziner die länder und
kommunen dazu aufgerufen haben möglichst
rasch viele menschen in sozial
benachteiligten stadtteilen zu impfen um
auch die krankenhäuser zu entlasten
warum hat die politik dieses problem
bislang so ausgeklammert in der kroner
debatte
ich denke die politik hat das gar nicht
ausgeklammert und uns ist das auch schon
seit wochen bekannt dass in dieser
dritten welle die sozialraum gebiete
besonders betroffen sind aber auch
politik und auch die kommunen die ja die
arbeit vor ort machen können eben nicht
alles gleichzeitig machen bisher war
noch nicht genug impfstoff da das ändert
sich jetzt und dann wird man
schrittweise das anpassen und ich hoffe
sehr dass wir in wenigen wochen in
wenigen vielleicht in zwei monaten eine
durchimpfung erreicht haben die uns dann
wirklich unsere freiheiten zurückgibt
vielen dank für dieses gespräch
sehr gern